[Musique]
ah les cabinets de curiosités petits
papillons sous cloche minéraux précieux
orné d'or ils sont de véritables écrins
hyper chic de collection d'objets chelou
l'art la nature et la science y est
coquine depuis la renaissance et encore
aujourd'hui ils sont de vrais phénomènes
de mode en 1492 christophe colomb
découvre l'amérique et c'est précisément
dans ce contexte d'exploration
géographique et de découverte de
nouvelles terres que les premiers
cabinets de curiosités naissent à la fin
du xvème siècle en europe et plus
précisément en italie du nord sous le
nom de studio les ce sont des lieux
privés dédiés à l'étude et au savoir
qu'ils sont réservés à créer une
ambiance favorisant ce que l'on appelle
la libido sciendi ou le désir
d'apprendre d'embrasser la connaissance
le tout dans un esprit d'émerveillement
d'étonnement et de contemplation à
l'époque la vision du monde change dans
les esprits s'élargit et ouvre des
portes sur de nouvelles sciences tout ça
va alors titiller la curiosité de prince
de savants ou encore de riches amateurs
de cette époque il se met alors à
convoiter et collectionner des objets
curieux dans une optique de condenser et
matérialiser une certaine vision du
monde qui est résumée à ces objets les
collectionneurs vont convoiter autant
d'objets naturels venant des quatre
coins du monde comme des coquillages ou
des végétaux séchés que des objets
artificiels comme des instruments
scientifiques des livres ou des oeuvres
d'art par exemple mais aussi des
bizarreries en tout genre et ils vont
ensuite les réunir dans des lieux dédiés
le concept arrive ensuite à munich sous
le nom de kunz kamer qui deviendra
lui-même le modèle de ce qu'on appelle
les bunder kamer qui signifie
littéralement chambre des merveilles
[Musique]
on les appelle les collectionneurs ou
les curieux étymologiquement parlant
curiosité vient de cure à qui veut dire
la cure comme dans cure ou curatif donc
littéralement le curieux devient celui
ou celle qui prend soin savants ou
collectionneurs principe rassemble et
possède une collection incroyable
d'objets rares et mystérieux et plus une
collection était grande et comportait
deux pièces rares plus cela a ajouté
évidemment au prestige social de son
propriétaire c'est une vraie
démonstration de faste et de richesses
parce que pour être collectionneur il
fallait avoir un peu de thunes du coup
le besoin de trouver un lieu dédié pour
entasser toutes ces petites merveilles
et petites babioles à vis de pointer le
bout de son nez et quand on a de la
thune et ben on voit les choses en grand
à la renaissance en italie on amasse des
objets dans des pièces de riches
demeures et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que l'accumulation il est alors le
mot d'ordre les collectionneurs accumule
toutes les merveilles possible de
l'univers dans les limites d'une pièce
étroite dans une volonté de reconstituer
un monde en miniature et d'en offrir une
image hante éligibles ces lieux sont
souvent et 3 privé secret personnel mais
aussi spectaculaire l'ambiance est bien
particulière et laisse entrevoir une
organisation spatiale imaginé par son
collectionneurs ils peuvent aussi
prendre la forme de meubles construits
sur mesure pour mettre en boîte le monde
et c'était pas genre votre étagère billy
de chez ikea non mais plutôt des meubles
ultra sophistiquée et très stylé souvent
en ébène en noyer ou en sapin c'était un
meuble incrusté de petites pierres ou
des cayes il est conçu pour accumuler et
dispose d'une multitude de petits
tiroirs débordant d'objets entassé ses
meubles sont placés dans des salles
reculer ou des chambres un plan team
pour favoriser l' isolement et la
contemplation pour donner envie de
connaître le monde
bon le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
les traces qu'on a des premiers cabinets
de curiosités font penser à des bons
gros bordel parce que c'est bien
d'accumuler mais comment il faisait pour
un peu rangée toutes ces pièces en mode
random du coup que contenaient ces
cabinets de curiosités et comment
s'organise style si des représentations
gravé et des catalogues publié nous
soufflent leurs contenus de l'époque il
semblerait qu'à chaque curieux son
propre cabinet et sa propre organisation
ils contiennent tous des mélange
hétéroclite d'objets comme des animaux
en bocaux des herbiers les pierres
précieuses des instruments scientifiques
des peintures des taxidermie des
antiquités mais aussi des morceaux
d'animaux légendaire voici une estampe
datant de 1655 présenté sur une double
page en frontispice d'un ouvrage du
xviie siècle intitulé museum voor miel
ou historiens c'est l'une des premières
représentations d'un cabinet de
curiosités et c'est celui de lost world
un professeur de médecine d'origine
danoise est considéré comme le fondateur
de l'archéologie nordiques et cette
gravure nous souffle comment ces lieux
tentaient de s'organiser on y voit
l'intérieur d'une pièce dans laquelle
sont accumulés un tas d'objets du sol au
plafond et sur les étagères comme des
carapaces de tortues des armes des
coquillages des crânes dépôt des
statuettes et des objets insolites dans
des boîtes mais aussi des coraux des
cailloux des végétaux on y perçoit au
milieu du désordre ambiant d inscription
en latin sur les boîtes des étagères
indiquant finalement une certaine
volonté de classer ce gros bordel si
chaque curieux expérimentent des
solutions personnelles pour tenter de
redonner ses collections elles
s'organisent généralement en quatre
catégories distincts les naturalia pour
tout ce qui concerne le minéral l'animal
et le végétal les artificiers alia pour
les objets façonnés par l'humain comme
les antiquités et les oeuvres d'art les
exotiques à pour les plantes et animaux
exotiques et les objets provenant de
pays lointains les scientifiques à pour
les objets scientifiques comme des
instruments par exemple ou encore les
mirabilia pour les objets bizarres
suscitant l'émerveillement ces derniers
recelait des collections d'objets
étranges et inusuelles réunis dans des
maisons particulières destinées à être
consultés par des esprits éduqués et
raffinée c'est à dire les classes
fortunées selon l'anthropologue gilles
boëtsch parallèlement à la zoologie
classique les cabinets de curiosités
cherchait aussi à réunir des fragments
de créatures du monde de légendes sans
oublier les mains corps imaginaire censé
avoir appartenu à tel ou tel monstre
célébrée dans la littérature ou les
contes populaires au travers de ces
catégories un soin tout particulier est
apporté à la présentation des objets ils
sont ornés suspendus au plafond mis en
cloche dressé sur des promontoires
précieux fabriqués par des artisans ou
encore accrochées aux murs comme des
peintures de maîtres pour souligner la
préciosité et le côté unique de ses
pièces ici le banal n'a pas sa place les
objets doivent être rares remarquable et
susciter l'émerveillement pour mettre en
valeur ses pièces les curieux font appel
à des artisans pour les restaurer les
lycées les polir mais altérant parfois
la pièce originale à l'extrême dans un
article sur les coquillages jean
baptiste la marque ou jean baptiste
pierre antoine de monet chevaliers de la
marque lancia ou jb pour les intimes si
vous préférez grand naturaliste et père
du transformisme en france notent que
les coquilles était souvent dénaturé et
mutilé par l'art les coquilles son lit
mais usé poli pour faire ressortir la
nacre ce qui fait disparaître les
écailles et tubercules caractéristiques
de celle ci empêchant de les identifier
correctement un contraste s'installe
donc petit à petit entre ce désir des
curieux de provoquer l'émerveillement au
maximum et celui des savants de vouloir
identifier
caractérisé ces pièces rares proposées
petit à petit les fondements de
l'histoire naturelle et cette volonté de
sublimer les curiosités va parfois si
loin que les curieux n'hésite pas par
exemple à monter des coquillages rare
sur du bronze doré pour les transformer
en récipient par exemple comme des
guerres des genres de carafes d'eau des
oeufs d'autruche ou des noix de coco
deviennent quant à elle des jolies
coupes dans une volonté d'entrecroiser
le naturel et l'artificiel pour
compléter la création divine naturelles
et la création artificielle de la main
de l'humain mais si les cabinets de
curiosités offre des objets précieux et
qu'un quand il aussi les vitrines d'une
nature imparfaite et étrange l'attirance
vers le blizzard et les anomalies de la
nature se manifeste également dans des
curiosités témoignant de sa nature
accidentelle voir monstrueuse
la tératologie et l'étude scientifique
des anomalies anatomiques héréditaire ou
congénitale cette discipline s'est
développée à partir du xviiie siècle
mais les monstres suscite intérêt
fascination depuis la plus lointaine
antiquité dans certaines cultures on
leur attribue et même des vertus
prophétique ainsi sept cents ans avant
jésus-christ les chaldéens gravés sur
des tablettes d'argile les prédictions
liés à certaines malformations par
exemple si un enfant né cesse en main
droite le pays subirait un tremblement
de terre et si la reine a accouché d'un
enfant à six orteils leroy gouvernerait
un territoire ennemi on pense aussi que
la représentation de certains dieux a pu
être influencé par des anomalies
physiques par exemple le cas du dieu
grec janus dont les deux visages
rappellent ceux des génisses eps des
jumeaux à deux faces dont le nom fait
référence à la divinité on peut aussi
citer les dieux hindous à plusieurs
membres qui auraient pu être inspiré par
l'observation de jumeaux conjoint ou
encore tout le bestiaire mythologique
avec les sirènes ou les cyclopes avec le
temps et les avancées scientifiques les
superstitions liées aux monstres vont
laisser place à l'analyse on comprend
que les malformations sont le fruit d'
incident biologique et qu'elles ne sont
pas dues à des amours démoniaque par
exemple comme on pouvait le croire au
moyen-âge c'est avec le naturaliste
etienne geoffroy saint-hilaire au début
du 19e siècle que la tératologie va
vraiment devenir une science celui ci
comprend que ces anomalies anatomiques
sont liés à un mauvais développement de
l'embryon à partir de cette époque on
assiste à un nouvel engouement pour les
monstres non plus comme créature
surnaturelle mais comme objet d'étude
les médecins et les chirurgiens vont
chercher à obtenir les spécimens les
plus étranges pour les placer dans leur
cabinet des curiosités et certains ont
moins de scrupules que d'autres c'est
notamment le cas de robert liston dans
les années 1830 ce chirurgien écossais
voulait à tout prix étudiant enfants
hydrocéphales vivant dans la campagne
londonienne une pathologie entraînant
une excroissance crânienne
impressionnante l'enfant était si
convoitée par les savants qu'à sa mort
en 1838 ses parents fiers garder sa
tombe pour la protéger des profanateurs
un mois plus tard cependant la dépouille
avait disparu liston ni à toute
implication dans cette histoire mais en
1840 il publia dans son livre element of
surgery un dessin de squelettes
d'enfants hydrocéphale qui rappelait
étrangement celui du jeune garçon au
début du 19e siècle le zoologiste
isidore geoffroy-saint-hilaire poursuit
l'oeuvre de son père et publie un traité
qui fera date dans l'histoire de la
tératologie histoire générale et
particulière des anomalies de
l'organisation chez l'homme et les
animaux dans cet ouvrage qui sera
notamment cité par darwin saint-hilaire
propose une classification anatomiques
des monstres en quatre niveaux allant
d'un nouvel i simples tels que les
cyclos cfa lien doté d'un sommeil à des
anomalies très complexe et graves comme
des monstres composés qui sont
principalement formé par la fusion de
deux corps mais malgré ces avancées
scientifiques pour le grand public le
statut des monstres ne change pas
vraiment il reste ce que l'on montre
qu'elle sait d'ailleurs l'étymologie du
terme comme en témoigne le succès des
frites chaudes l'époque les gens restent
fascinés par l'étrange et le blizzard
[Musique]
et ce goût pour l'étrange et le blizzard
va aussi se retrouver dans des pièces
qu'on appelle alors les me rhabille des
objets à la limite de la magie au
pouvoir occulter talismanique comme du
sang de dragon séchées ou des squelettes
d'animaux légendaire qui vont
ouvertement flirté avec la fausse
science une des curiosités qu'on
s'arrache à l'époque et le rémora un
poisson ventouses à tête plate alors
ouais ok comme ça c'est pas très sexy
mais il est à l'époque dans tous les
cabinets de curiosités pourtant assez
classique d'apparence est très répandue
il déchaîne les passions il est en fait
convoité car très présent dans une vaste
littérature lui étant consacré et ça
depuis l'antiquité la légende raconte
qu'il a des pouvoirs surnaturels et
qu'il est même capable d'arrêter un
navire dans sa course en se collant à
lui cette légende fut lancée par ovide
puis développé par pline l'ancien qui
parle d'une galère qui fut arrêté par un
rémora empêchant le massacre des jeunes
garçons de l'île de cnide le cabinet de
curiosités devient donc le théâtre du
fantastique les sciences et les
croyances populaires flirt et
s'entremêlent les pierres d'origine
animale font aussi fureur comme les
fossiles mais aussi les concrétions pour
le moins 20 solide par exemple les bge
aux harkis sont des pierres que l'on
trouve dans le corps de certains
quadrupèdes c'est une concrétion
légèrement souple formé de couches
concentriques autour d'un corps étranger
dans l'appareil digestif de certains
ruminants comme les chèvres et il est à
l'époque considéré comme un anti poison
extrêmement puissants aux vertus
magiques et curative et plus il est gros
plus il a des vertus et donc bah pluie
les chairs et les baies zohar sont même
parfois ornées sur de somptueuses
monture en or alors qu'on parle
littéralement d'un corps étranger ou
d'un amas de débris comme des poils ou
des aliments impossible à digérer c'est
un genre de cailloux de vomi de chèvre
un peu quoi et cette quête du
merveilleux va mener à voir apparaître
des prétendus restes d'animaux mythique
les cornes de licorne par exemple qui
sont en fait des dents de narval ont une
place de choix chez les collectionneurs
malgré leurs rares c'est la pièce qui
prouve à l'époque l'existence de cet
animal légendaire saboter fascine par
son ivoire torsadé mesurant parfois
jusqu'à deux mètres de long la corne de
licorne se vend entière 8 à 10 fois le
prix de son poids en or ou en tranches
fines et parfois en poudre cet aspect de
profil va faire la joie et la fortune
des vendeurs et négociants de l'époque
on voit alors se mettre en place un vrai
marché de pièces fantastique en tout
genre qui se vendent à prix d'or comme
des museaux de poissons scies qu'on fait
passer pour des langues de dragon ou des
quartz qu'on identifie comme étant de la
glace éternelle naissent alors de
véritable chimère taxidermisé dans le
but de prouver l'existence d' animaux
légendaires et de faire de la bonne
grosse tune
[Musique]
oh
parce que je préfère dans les cabinets
de curiosité c'est les bestioles
complètement foireuse seller taxidermie
complètement raté des trucs comme ça
c'est assez marrant d'ailleurs il ya des
compiles qui circulent sur le net et
dans le lot il y en a un que j'aime
beaucoup c'est le lion de grippe ce vol
tx parce qu'il connaît lui comme ça
et en fait ils datent du xviiie c'est
quand le roi de suède de l'époque a reçu
un cadeau diplomatique
voilà donc un lion vivant qui l'a mis
dans ses jardins royaux en toute
simplicité en scandinavie normale est
quoi ce lion est mort du coup ils ont
pris sakho ses autres ça ils ont tout
donné à un taxidermiste en disant bas
accompli ta magie sauf que le problème
c'est que le taxidermiste n'avait jamais
vu de lyon vivant et il n'avait pas la
notice du coup il a fait comme il a pu
et force est de constater que ça
ressemble à rien
mais c'est assez courant avec les
animaux exotiques ce genre les girafes
aussi les gens pensaient que les girafes
n'existait pas alors que de l'autre côté
il avait des cornes de licorne tu l'as
dit non dans leurs cabinets de
curiosités savard faisait pas peur
commence assez dans le même genre il ya
l'ornithorynque les premiers naturaliste
qui ont reçu des ornithorynques des
cadavres comme ça non mais attendez
c'est un canular ce truc qui a collé un
bec de canard sur un corps de castor ils
ont cherché les points de couture et
tout mais ils les ont pas trouvées
forcément de l'autre côté ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'il ya des canulars qui
passaient complètement inaperçue à
l'époque ça allait très bien de gens la
truite poilus c'est un mythe north
america islandais des gens qui pensaient
que il y avait des truites qui vivaient
dans des eaux très froides et qui du
coup avait développé des fourrures
autour d'eux et du coup il ya des mecs
un peu un peu rigolo qui sont dit on va
coller des fourrures de lapin sur
détruite on va les vendre comme ça ces
gens un peu crédule et ça a très bien
marché et dans le même genre il ya le
jackalope pareil légende noire
américaine dans un mix entre un jack
rabbit donc un lièvre et une antilope
donc un lièvre avec des espèces de corne
et ça c'est ultra courants aux états
unis fin j'en viens à plein conte des
trophées avec des têtes de jackalope
gens même ronald reagan son jackalope
chez lui et a évidemment ça c'est une
supercherie
le jackalope par ronald reagan mais ce
qui est marrant c'est que ça se base sur
une vraie histoire c'est qu'en fait tu
peux voir effectivement des lapins et
des élèves qui se baladent avec des
espèces de cornes sur le visage de tous
mais en fait c'est quand c'est des
tumeurs due à un papillomavirus donc
c'est pas cool pour eux mais c'est
rigolo parce que du coup c'est là que la
réalité rejoint la la légende un peu
comme dans les cabinets de curiosité ou
si c'est pas beau tout ça
finalement il est très clair que les
cabinets de curiosités sont à l'époque
réservé à une élite c'est une activité
réservée exclusivement à des bourgeois
éduqués et fortunés qui ont plutôt une
volonté de posséder et d'organiser le
monde par eux mêmes dans un espace
restreint plutôt que de partager et
donner accès aux savants par exemple à
des pièces rares qui poseront les
fondements de notre histoire naturelle
et de la classification moderne les
cabinets de curiosités sont petit à
petit considéré au xviiie siècle comme
l'expression de la vanité de l'être
humain georges louis leclerc comte de
buffon éminent naturaliste n'hésitera
pas à écrire dans son ouvrage histoire
naturelle que les curieux sont des
personnes aisées qui s'ennuient et
collectionne tout et n'importe quoi en
dépensant juste des sommes astronomiques
et sous leurs airs de cabinet magique et
précieux se cache une autre facette ils
font leur apparition en plein essor du
colonialisme les colons étant bien
souvent soucieux de prouver aux
autochtones leur supériorité qu'elle
soit intellectuelle morale ou
spirituelle dont des démonstrations de
sciences ou encore de religion et
collecter et volé des objets exotiques
de ces populations devient également
monnaie courante pour illustrer cette
facette obscure parlant de hand sloan un
médecin et naturaliste anglais du xviiie
qui deviendra ensuite le fondateur du
british muséum et dont le travail et le
mérite se base sur l'esclavagisme cet
homme passe sa vie à assembler et
collectionner des objets et des
spécimens rares provenant du monde
entier dans un souci de concilier vision
scientifique et création divine du monde
au travers de ses découvertes et sa
collection brille par sa rareté il
réunit plus de 45 mille livres 3100 son
manuscrit des herbiers des insectes des
taxidermie les minéraux et ça par
milliers mais pour obtenir ces pièces il
n'hésite pas à se précipiter sur les
collections prestigieuses de ses
confrères des cds pour s'attribuer tout
le mérite de ces curiosités il est
d'ailleurs très très peu apprécié du
milieu newton n'hésitons carrément pas à
le qualifier de scélérats de gredins ou
même de véritables escrocs mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là lorsqu'il part rejoindre
sa nouvelle femme en jamaïque il devient
propriétaire d'esclaves dans des
plantations de canne à sucre et ils
méprisent littéralement leurs savoirs
botanique il demandera à ses esclaves
africains de lui montrer des spécimens
de plantes rares de lui faire visiter
l'île et il obtiendra un précieux savoir
qu'il s'appropriera sans vergogne dans
un livre nommé histoire de la jamaïque
et qui est en fait concrètement rendue
possible par l' esclavage il ira même
jusqu'à récupérer des banjos appartenant
à des esclaves pour les mettre dans sa
collection quand il rentre en angleterre
il demande aux marchands d'esclaves de
lui envoyer des spécimens il
collectionne alors les vêtements portés
par les esclaves les noeuds coulants et
les fouets utilisé pour punir et
exécuter les fuyards il obtient des
spécimens de peau humaine des crânes il
fait partie de cette première génération
de savants intéressé à essayer de
déterminer s'il y a une base physique
pour les différences raciales
les cabinets de curiosités sont aussi
parfois le moyen d'offrir une
démonstration de pouvoir d'une nation
voire d'une race au fil des années et
avec sa santé qui décline vers 1730 hand
clown va avoir l'idée de faire don de
ses collections à sa mort à la nation
dans un lieu accessible à tous et afin
de montrer l'étendue de la beauté de la
création divine en 1753 le parlement
britannique adopte le british muséum
actes il le musée rempli d'objets
appartenant à d'autres cultures ouvre
ses portes le 15 janvier 1759 petit à
petit les cabinets de curiosités vont
alors donné naissance à les lieux de
conservation institutionnels et des
musées ce sont les réels ancêtres de nos
muséum d'histoire naturelle en plus de
ça la diversité des collections
disponibles offrent aux yeux des
scientifiques des spécimens rares et
uniques une réelle aubaine pour la
science si les savants mots-clés cabinet
de curiosités ils admettent aussi leur
importance en 1817 jean baptiste la
marque publie un article sur les
coquillages sous ses propos critiques il
admet que si les scientifiques ont pu
voir beaucoup de coquillages rare et
bien c'est grâce aux collectionneurs et
c'est sur ces collections que va se
consolider l'idée d'avoir une
classification du vivant au 19e siècle
ces pièces constituent la base même des
collections des musées d'histoire
naturelle et d'art aujourd'hui encore en
arpentant des lieux comme le british
muséum où la galerie d'anatomie comparée
du muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris
on peut encore sentir cet univers
mettant en scène des objets naturels et
curieux si les cabinets de curiosités
sont revenus à la mode ces dernières
années aux yeux du grand public en
séduisant par leur étrangeté et leur
aspect décoratif il est important de
comprendre l'histoire de ces objets
fascinants sous leurs airs de gros
bordel d'objets insolites et malgré un
passé est bordée de colonialisme ils
sont les premiers échantillonnage de ce
qui constitue le fondement même de notre
histoire naturelle moderne en
participant à l'époque à des changements
importants dans la vision et la
compréhension scientifique de notre
monde
[Musique]
bon ben voilà c'est la première fois que
je monte mon travail comme ça donc je
suis un peu stressé mais le but c'était
vraiment de vous rendre hommage à chacun
dans la maison à un hommage carrément
ouais mais un hommage alternatif tu vois
genre qui sort des sentiers battus c'est
mortel il y avait un bout de saucisson
et punk j'ai mangé la veille pourrait
pas être mieux représentés
c'est des poêles à bas certains
donnaient leur personne baky ce qui est
ce vous plaît pas c'est ça j'en ai vu
des trucs dégueulasses mais là je
m'incline
[Musique]